de bonis wieder ausgebrochen und dieses
mal geht es schneller als beim letzten
schlimmsten ausbruch in der geschichte
der menschheit schon jetzt haben sich
die ausbrüche in ein gebiet ausgebreitet
wo die krankheitsfälle 60 kilometer
auseinander liegen bereits in dieser
frühen phase ist eine millionenstadt
bedroht doch es gibt einen lichtblick
zum ersten mal gibt es einen impfstoff
doch der ist in afrika gar nicht so
leicht einzusetzen jetzt in kriegszeiten
weg schmerz bekommen
ich möchte ja nicht den teufel an die
wand malen aber beim letzten ausbruch
2014 bis 2016 nach klicks um als
einziger berichterstatter richtig und
hat zum einen die informationen aus
afrika korrekt bedeutet und damit den
erheblichen ausbruch genau so
vorhergesehen und zum anderen waren wir
auch das einzige medium das dran
geblieben ist und nicht irgendwann müde
wurde über die neuesten entwicklungen zu
berichten
nur bei uns war über die wochen genau zu
verfolgen was dort in afrika geschah ja
und wie die solche sich langsam
ausbreitete und am ende mehr als 11.000
todesopfer forderte ein unglaublicher
ausbruch der kaum zu stoppen schiene und
auch dieses mal scheint schon der
ausbruch bisher nicht gemeldet worden zu
sein
seit dem vierten april gibt es 32
bestätigte ebola fälle im kongo aber
jetzt erst wird er vermeldet 18 menschen
sind bereits gestorben und das verheißt
nichts gutes denn unter den erkrankten
sind drei pfleger von denen einer
bereits gestorben ist und pfleger sind
die besten verbreiter einer solchen
solche da sie zu vielen menschen kontakt
haben
ja das war so ähnlich auch bei der
letzten solche hier war eine heilerin
eine super verbreiterung bei ihrer
trauerfeier kamen hunderte menschen
steckten sich an und verbreiteten die
solche jetzt sieht die
weltgesundheitsorganisation whu bereits
die millionenstadt bahn dakar
eingefahren hat auch alle nachbarstaaten
des kongo in alarmbereitschaft versetzt
jetzt am wochenende sollen rund 40
expertinnen und experten in den kongo
geflogen werden und die will zum ersten
mal einen impfstoff einsetzen der ist
zwar noch nicht zugelassen
aber im gegensatz zum letzten
katastrophalen ausbruch der seuche will
die wehr jetzt deutlich schneller und
effektiver handeln so einen dramatischen
verlauf den soll es nicht mehr geben
doch bei dem neuen impfstoff der firma
merck gibt es einen haken er muss bei
temperaturen von achtung - 60 - 80 grad
celsius transportiert werden in afrika
eine nahezu unlösbare aufgabe ob sie
gelingen wird darüber halten wir euch
hier wie auch beim letzten ausbruch auf
dem laufenden wenn er also nichts zum
ebola ausruf verpassen wollt uns als
erster informiert werden wollt dann
endet meine telefonnummer hierbei
whatsapp und den anderen messengern dann
erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen
vom neuesten video täglich garantiert
einfach hier draufklicken unser brüssel
habe ich ein kleines goodie und
natürlich nicht das womit der
genau mit dem blogger vergessen und hier
geht es weiter dafür auch draufklicken
beginnt ein neuer kampf gegen ebola
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran